devil fruits are the most important
power in one piece but have you ever
thought to yourself wow I mean I wish
that this power would be in the story as
well well I had the very same idea and
asked all of you to submit your wildest
most powerful and incredulous devil
fruits that would absolutely break one
piece and uh you won't believe how hard
it was to sort through almost
2,000 submissions from all of you to
pick out just 15 of the coolest devil
fruit hours that honestly you will
probably ever see okay but first of all
let's start with just how completely
insane this contest developed because
after the very first minute 60 seconds
that the contest was open I already saw
three Banger devil food ideas and I just
knew at this point that this was going
to be a massive challenge to pick just
15 and also I just have to give a huge
huge thank you to everyone from all over
the world who submitted your devil
fruits I mean I just love to see that
this amazing Community comes together so
much in such an awesome way to come up
with these Powers although of course I
have to be honest I did not take into
consideration any submissions that were
actually already fruits in the story and
if there were repeat devil fruit
submissions like the over 100 water
fruits the 42 blood fruits and the 37
air/w type fruits then I just had to
pick the submission with the best
explanation of powers and limitations
and yeah speaking of limitations and
weaknesses I mean any submission that
was just insane stupidly broken with
absolutely no restrictions whatsoever
like the universe fruit that just lets
you literally do anything that you want
I had to throw out those as well because
there's no devil fruit in the story as
you know that doesn't have some sort of
restriction or downside to its power as
well and the final disclaimer here is
that this video is not just about strong
fighting fruits but also in general
includes those ones that are just
stupidly useful in many other creative
ways and would break the world that way
and the perfect example of this is the
first one on our list which is the Buu
bomi the bottle fruit submitted by
Martin which basically has my favorite
devil fruit design in this entire
ranking I mean look at it it's just this
like super creative like ship in the
bottle theme but now what does this
fruit actually do well it does give you
the ability to shrink anything down to a
tiny size and store it inside a pocket
Dimension inside one of these bottles
that you can create which doesn't sound
all that special at first maybe but let
me explain here imagine you're stuck at
the red line but you don't want to go
underwater to Fishman Island well with
this fruit you can just put your ship in
a bottle and carry it over the red line
in your pocket or imagine that you want
to just sneak attack kind of let's say
Marine Fort for instance with this fruit
you can literally keep an entire Armada
in a single bottle and when you're ready
to fight smashing the bottle will
release the entire Army which is simply
incredible for sneaking around and
transporting anything storing anything
but it also has some truly overpowered
combat abilities as well for instance
you can trap fire or lightning in a
bottle yeah lightning in a bottle and
then release it to defeat an opponent so
yeah truly a not only insanely creative
but also overpowered and Incredibly
useful devil fruit plus again that
design well done Martin thank you
however even this insane ability here is
not as useful as the sentient me which
was submitted by Musa from India now
this power is absurdly broken and if
used by the right person could
completely tear down the entire world
government let's be real that's because
the ability of the Senti senoi lets you
learn anything about a person or object
by simply touching it and when I say
everything I mean everything now to
perfectly demonstrate how broken this
fruit is let's say you ate it and then
touched a poneglyph well you would now
know not only what it says but also who
made it when and where it was made and
possibly even where the others like it
were placed around the world or let's
say if you touched a world Noble then
you would learn all their Dark Secrets
including information that the world
government would never want you to know
so yeah if that isn't an insanely
overpowered fruit in a pirate treasure
hunt kind of story then I don't know
what it is but that's not all because in
combat you could use this fruit to learn
all of your opponent's weaknesses and
then come up with the best way to
counter them and really the only
downside to this would be that you kind
of trans out for a second here however
even the incredible knowledge that you
could gain from the ctif fruit doesn't
compare to the god tier abilities of
this next one and that's because with
the powers of Zak the zoda's snail snail
fruit model denden Mushi you can
instantly communicate with people all
over the world which you might be saying
well normal denden Mushi can already do
that but this power lets you communicate
with literally anyone without ever
needing the snail phone in the first
place which let's be honest how many
times during battles are you going to
pause to pick up the phone right and
this fruit truly shines with the ability
to have group calls inside of your head
cuz in case you don't know then and
mushies work telepathically that would
basically let you instantly coordinate
with your entire Squad SL Army to
strategize during an allout massive war
I mean just imagine how useful this
power would have been when the straw
heads were lost in the forest during
skypia or during the chaotic Battle of
onigashima where it was literally people
fighting all over the castle and in fact
this power would be perfect for a
strategist let's say like Sanji who
could organize everyone to fight in the
best possible locations which again yeah
isn't a super broken combat fruit on its
own though you would be a Zone fruit so
you still get all the boosts from that
but in a world as big as one piece
instant communication with whoever
wherever would be one of the most
overpowered abilities no doubt and this
next fruit here though is 100% a devil
fruit idea that I guarantee you probably
have never heard of and that's because
Keo from Italy submitted one of my
personal favorites in this ranking the
game game noi or I guess in Japanese it
would be the game G noi and now we've
had many really reality bending
submissions but this one is just so
unique and interesting that that just
had to include it on this list okay so
basically this fruit allows you to turn
yourself into a video game character and
treat the world around you like your
personal RPG Adventure game and that for
example means that you can just pause
everything during a battle to give
yourself time to think you can keep a
hidden inventory of up to 999 items and
you can even save your progress up to
three times and then return to one of
those safe points I mean come on who
wouldn't want to have this fruit and
just imagine you're about to get
absolutely like let's say crushed by
kaido well you can quickly just quit and
restart that boss fight though again
only three times simple as that and of
course what is a video game without an
incredible PowerUp system as well so
every time that you defeat an enemy you
gain stat points to level up your
strength your speed your health and
other abilities kind of like the sandbox
game where you can just like put points
to like different uh you know abilities
you have physically plus you can get
item drops and money for every enemy
that you defeat although of course let's
be real with a ridiculous power like
this there of course have to be some
limitations so you can't just restart as
many times as you like there has to be a
limit like a certain number of times per
day and every time that you restart you
lose any experience and the loot that
you might have gained since your last
let's say safe also pausing during a
battle or a fight that you're kind of
like already investing a lot of energy
in dramatically drains your stamina even
more so it's not like you can just do
that on an infinite Loop forever you
still lose that power that you know
devil fruit users have to use for their
powers and speaking of time fruits
though doesn't of submissions have had
time based Powers but South Africa's
Hassan submitted the so-called Chrono
Chrono noi the time time fruit which had
in my opinion the best combination of
super awesome time Powers with quite
reasonable limitations I think and
that's because this fruit gives the user
the ability to create time bubbles
around themselves and Within These
bubbles s they can freely speed up or
slow down time kind of like what laws
room does which is absolutely
devastating of course if you're fighting
someone one-on-one because while you
both would be moving at the same speed
inside the bubble you could easily
confuse them by changing the range off
speed at any given time and of course
time would be flowing normally outside
the bubble but if you're moving super
fast inside of it then you could quickly
Dash around a battlefield to avoid
attacks or simply get to the other side
by you know creating bubbles here or
there and in particular this fruit would
be perfect in a situation like the bird
cage from dress Rosa where you would
make a bubble around yourself and do
Flamingo to effectively speed up the
fight against the former warlord before
the string cage could do any more damage
to the city and then of course Awakening
this fruit could also mean that you
could create bigger time bubbles but
this power can also leave you quite
exhausted physically so you'd still need
to be pretty strong to use it
efficiently on a consistent basis which
honestly is the exact opposite of this
next fruit which might have the highest
power ceiling but also the lowest floor
of any fruit on this ranking because
this is the so-called Shar share fruit
which was submitted by couie from Japan
actually and this one is a little bit
complex so make sure you're paying
attention here now the base ability of
the share fruit allows you to
essentially share your physical
abilities with another person so
basically you get weak they get strong
the catch here is that once the person
that you gave your pow two dice you get
both your power back as well as all the
strength of the person that you shared
your power with and so let's say if
you're both just regular people once the
person dies you'd get double the power
back but let's say you give your power
to someone super incredibly strong like
Zoro or kaido then once they died you'd
get all of that strength back from them
in return as well and so really over
your entire life your power could grow
an insane amount depending on how many
times you share and get your powers back
and actually I'd love for a power like
this to even have like some sort of
extra special ability kind of like you
know LW Immortal surgery or something
like that where the power of each
previous user is then transferred to the
next person who eats the fruit so I
guess kind of like one for all powers
from myy your Academia which means that
you won't get much power if you're the
first person to eat the fruit but just
imagine if you're like the 10th person
to eat it then basically you'd have
Godly strengths from the moment you eat
the fruit and I could see it be
something like let's say like like the
secret treasure of marijua where it kind
of gets passed down through the
generations making each successive
person stronger and now it might sound a
little bit crazy to say but the next
power Now list makes you an even
deadlier weapon than any of the fruits
that we've discussed so far and that's
because not Rowan which is I guess
you're not Rowan then he submitted the
so-called doju fruit and man do I love
the concept of this one let me explain
it by touching an opponent or anything
you can basically drain their normal
abilities or Essence such as speed
strength and endurance and then turn
them into large drops of liquids you can
then take these duw drops of power and
give these abilities to yourself an ally
or even an inanimate object so for
instance if you were fighting Luffy you
could drain some of his insane stamina
and absorb that stamina yourself and an
awakened form of this power could even
let you take powers from inanimate
objects like fire and then give those
powers to another person plus there
aren't that many downsides to this fruit
either but one that maybe makes sense is
that you don't just gain your opponent's
Powers forever once you use up the
amount that you drained then it's
basically gone also of course if you
have strong hockey you could probably
resist the fruit which I guess is the
case for most other devil fruits as well
but only if they have stronger hockey
than yourself but if you thought that
this power was incredibly versatile then
just you wait until you hear about the
Zodiac devil fruit submitted by Falcon
fig of the United States of America and
with this being the only Zone in the top
15 except our dend Mushi fruit you can
bet that it is insanely creative now the
original idea is that this fruit would
Grant you the power of one of the zodiac
animals but honestly I think making this
a mythical Zone fruit could mean that
you can freely transform into any of the
zodiac animals I mean just think about
the incredible diversity of powers you
can easily sneak around as a small rat
or you can blast your way through an
entire Army as a massive Dragon I mean I
can just imagine the rabbit having super
speed and something like the ox just
being an insanely durable tank and since
this is the Zodiac we're talking about
you might even get an extra sort of
power boost depending on the time of the
year if it lines up with the animal that
you're using right now kind of the star
constellations so yeah I think quite an
awesome power to use in basically any
situations cuz it gives you 12 forms to
choose from basically depending on what
you need so love the concept however
nothing is as powerful I think as Derek
submitted devil fruit idea which is the
Sub sub no me which now is not what you
think it of course instantly lets you
subscribe to the channel for more one
piece content just like this plus there
is an infinite amount of these fruits
out there so go eat the fruit subscribe
and this next fruit though is almost too
deadly to even put into the story if
you're being honest because l v from the
Czech Republic submitted the kinoo
kinomi the mushroom mushroom fruit which
is a Loi ability that turns you into a
mushroom person that kind of is mushroom
spores I mean yeah I said that mushroom
spores and if you know anything about
mushrooms well then you should know that
this power can be absolutely terrifying
and absolutely lethal because as a
mushroom sport person you can turn your
body into literally billions of tiny
mushroom particles that could spread
through the air and if someone breathes
in these spores then well it's basically
game over for them because mushrooms
have a ton of really insane effects yes
there are a lot that heal you but some
are so poisonous that they can instantly
kill you others can make you hallucinate
or even make a person fall asleep which
means that you're basically Untouchable
from Clos range because anyone who hits
you would be immediately exposed to all
these tiny spores and to take this even
a step further Awakening this fruit
could let you turn your entire
environment into mushroom spores as well
which means that a whole Battlefield
could instantly become a poisonous
mindfield for anyone who gets too close
to you yeah definitely very op but uh
also very scary ability and I would love
to see that one in the story actually
and while this next devil fruit on the
list might not be as obviously powerful
at first glance it is simply one of my
favorite abilities in all of anime and
you'll see why but it has never shown up
in one piece and that is the dice dice
fruit which yeah I know Mr one's fruit
has the same name but this version
submitted by River from Canada involves
actual black and white dice you know the
one you use for gambling and wow I mean
let me explain how this abser power
works and why I love it so much so first
of all the user can summon a six-sided
die which has the numbers 1 to six on
each of the sides and then they throw it
out and whatever number it lands on that
effect is instantly used used by them
now what could these effects be well I'm
glad you asked because River actually
supplied a perfectly balanced list of
awesome abilities rolling a one for
example lets you blast a dice at your
opponent kind of like a bullet rolling a
two causes a flying Wicked slash kind of
like a curved sthe that can hit multiple
opponents a three causes damage to an
opponent and anyone within at least 6
feet radius of that person kind of like
a small explosion a number four causes a
raining dance of Blade like dies to rain
down on the battlefield rolling a five
instantly lowers an opponent's speed and
stamina and then rolling a number six
makes a floating Dart that hovers around
the user to attack anyone who gets near
you which if you ask me is all just
amazingly cool stuff if you ask I love
the random like gambling side to it but
of course the downside is that you can't
exactly choose what power is used at any
given moment reasonably also there might
also be like a short cooldown time
before you can roll your next die so if
you really need to roll a four and rain
down blades on a bunch of opponents you
might not get that anytime soon I mean
if you love math and statistics
calculate it yourself but now for this
next fruit something completely
different I want you to think about the
one thing that you want the most in the
world right now is it a giant stack of
money passing great on your next exam a
delicious sushi I don't know what you
want please please for me though the
sushi but with the hoko hoki submitted
by Ali from the US thank you ali uh you
can create a magical compass that kind
of puffs up that will then lead you to
whatever you desire the most in that
moment you know kind of like Jack
Sparrow compass from the Pirates of the
Caribbean movies if you know about that
so yeah finding the one piece like no
problem like at all with this fruit just
follow the direction that the compass is
pulling you towards and you will find it
eventually it could also help you find
another overpowered devil fruit to uh
sell or give to your friend and it even
has applications in battle when you
really think about it such as guiding
you to find the best path to winning and
you could probably even create a compass
on another person which will guide them
to what they desire most as well but now
I know that a bunch of you have been
waiting for this next ability because it
was the most submitted devil fruit after
the water fruit and that is of course
the blood fruit which again there was a
ton of fantastic of these ideas
submitted and I thank you for all of
them even if yours isn't the one I
picked right now but the option I chose
in the end was submitted by tush PK from
India because it just has the best
description of powers along with really
realistic limitations as well and like
the name says this fruit of course
allows you to produce and control blood
Halloween I guess is around the corner
now that means that you can whip out
deadly blood slashes for long range
attacks you can make a blood sword to
fight in close combat and yeah you can
even control the blood inside of another
person which kind of creeps me out a
little bit but I guess it's something
you all really seem to
enjoy but of course that also have to be
limitations on this simply broken
ability so for this fruit we would
probably have to say that you can't make
anyone kill themselves by stopping their
blood for instance I mean that would
just be way too evil but you can slow
down or speed up someone's blood to a
certain extent to make them slower or to
help them heal faster you could also
physically control their movements so
you can be an e evil puppet master of
course controlling another person can be
overcome if the other person is strong
enough so even if this isn't guaranteed
to win your fight it's still just I mean
insanely powerful and again a little bit
gory but
um you guys really love it so this is
why it's it let me tell you though if I
was a devil fruit user I would not want
to fight this next devil fruit even more
because at number three we have the
leech Leach fruit submitted by fata
which is a German word not is that your
real name I mean if it is cool and this
fruit powers are basically just like
what it sounds it lets you slowly drain
other people's Powers which is similar
to the due fruit that we discussed
earlier except this one drains devil
fruit abilities not just strength and
speed and that of course means that it's
the perfect power for a long drawn out
fight against a devil FR user because if
you can survive long enough and keep the
fight going your opponent will
eventually get weaker and weaker over
time just by being around you a perfect
example for this would be a marathon
likee fight against kaido that Luffy had
which if you had this fruit and could
survive for as long as Luffy did you
might actually stand a chance at taking
down one of these powerhouses if you
just keep them busy long enough and to
take it one step further a possible
Awakening for this fruit could also
drain your opponent's normal strength as
well which means that in a long fight
you're basically guaranteed to win if
they don't like get you right out of the
gate though even this leech devil fruit
is not as overpowered as this next one
at two which I'm honestly kind of
shocked that it does not already exist
in one piece in the first place and
that's because sahat from Nepal
submitted the Yumi yum noi thank you
sahat which in English I guess would be
the dreamdream fruit and this fruit is
mind blowingly useful in just so so many
situations I mean the first Power of
this fruit allows you to put someone to
sleep by simply touching them which you
know is already ridiculously useful in
any fight but that's really just a start
of it because once your target is asleep
you can then manipulate their dream in
the following ways you could change and
manipulate the dreams however you want
which could be either incredibly
enjoyable or absolutely terrifying of
course you can also physically attack
your Target in the dream world which
wouldn't damage their actual body
because that's just too absurdly broken
let's be real but enough damage and you
could break their mind and this power
also would allow you to communicate
through dreams so you can talk to an
ally as long as they would be asleep
somewhere in the world and to top it all
off Awakening this fruit could also let
the user manifest their dream Creations
into the real world to a certain degree
which yeah if you've ever had any wild
and crazy and really nightmarish dreams
like I have then you should know just
how insane and terrifying that ability
truly is which now brings us to the
number one best devil fruit that would
break the one piece world that you guys
submitted which is the play play Fruit
submitted by Joe clearly not an average
Joe because at first I thought this
would just be you know kind of like the
game fruit that we discussed earlier but
how was I wrong I mean just listen to
this the basic power of this fruit
allows you to make any sort of game into
a binding contest in the real world for
example if you're in a fight against a
super strong opponent you can use this
fruit to turn the fight into a game that
decides the outcome and yeah to truly
understand how broken this is let's just
imagine you or I ate this fruit and
strolled up to Blackbeard well of course
there's no way that we would ever beat
an emperor like Blackbeard in a fight
but using the fruit here we could just
make it so that he has to play a life
and death game of rock paper scissors
the loser is literally killed sure I
mean to be fair it might be a 50/50
chance but it's in initely better than
having no chance at all right for
another perfect example let's say bouncy
Hunter Zoro comes to collect the bouncy
on your head well instead of fighting
you simply challenge him to erase
through a mace and you will 100% beat
the always lost swordsman so yeah a
truly broken ability especially if you
know your opponent's weaknesses because
with its powers even a regular person
has a chance to defeat the strongest
characters in the story but if you
actually end up in the one piece world
and you want a true cheat code to become
super powerful in one piece then there's
really nothing better that you can do
than eat one of these five actual devil
fruits in one piece and if you want to
see exactly what those broken devil
fruits are you can click that video
right here again a huge shout out to
everyone all over the world who
submitted all your I mean your your
ideas were just insane let's be real I
was actually moved and it was really a
blessing to see the huge variety of
countries represented in the community
like part of this channel love that
super excited to do this again very soon
in fact if you want to see 15 more
fruits from the almost 2,000 submitted
ones there's so many cool ones left let
me know in the comments I will'll make
that happen for now Shanks for watching
and I will see you in the next one thank
you